Wesley yang reported that
you met with Tech Titans,
Marc Andreessen and Peter Teal,
both of whom advocate
decentralized education.
Can you share anything about this?
Um,
I don't know if I can
share anything interesting.
I mean,
I enjoyed the meeting mark and Peter.
I met mark several times.
Um,
I've only met Peter Wants,
although I've spent some time with
Eric Weinstein who works with Peter,
you know,
Peter is Libertarian oriented.
Um,
and so
he,
he shares concerns about the potential
totalitarian function of Internet
technology and manifesting itself well in,
in the constant monitoring
of our behavior and also in,
in the emergent censorship.
Let's say Marc Andreessen,
well Mark's a smart guy and he knows
a lot of other smart guys and we,
we spent a lot of time talking about
the possibility of online education and,
and uh,
but there isn't anything really
exciting I can report about that.
I mean they were all
preliminary discussions of a
sort to see if we could get
long and if we could talk.
And so far we've been able to,
I am making a fair bit of headway
with this university project,
although we don't really conceptualize
it as a university project anymore.
We're conceptualizing it as an adaptive
learning system and we're trying to use
it to index people's no index knowledge
on the web funnel money to creative
producers of educational content,
allow people to test their knowledge
no matter how it's generated and to
accredit people properly.
And we'll release,
release more information about that in
the upcoming months as we move closer and
closer to a functional prototype.
The plan at the moment,
I've talked to lots of
people like Andrea said,
and teal who,
who are very interested in technology
and education and who also are very well
capitalized and have had the opportunity
multiple times to pull in investors
into this educational project.
But I haven't done that
partly because weirdly enough,
you know,
you think money is a
solution to a problem,
but it's also,
it's often a problem in and of itself.
And if I generated
several million dollars,
let's say,
to fund this educational,
um,
endeavor,
then I would not only have to worry about
how to design the educational system,
but then I'd have to worry about how to
spend that money and shepherd that money
intelligently.
And that's actually a huge administrative
problem of sufficient magnitude to
stop you from doing any
creative thinking at all.
So what we're doing instead is I'm funding
the university project at the moment
or the online education project as a
consequence of my patriot and funding car.
Fixed that in about
five seconds this time.
So,
um,
okay.
I'm finding that from my Patriot patrion
donations and I like that better.
The only problem is,
is that I would like to offer the people
that I have his employees a certain
amount of financial stability.
And so,
and you know,
it isn't obvious to me how
stable the Patriot on funding is,
although it's been very stable so far.
But you know,
who knows how that will work out.
So I think what we're going to do is to
crowd fund in October or November once
we have a minimal viable product.
And I think I'd rather do that than
raise money privately anyways because I
don't want this project
to be beholden to anyone.
And I wanted to maintain control over
its direction with a small group of
programmers.
You know,
it's often a small group of people who
are working tightly together that solve
very complicated problems.
And that's certainly been
the case with working.
Say with Daniel Higgins and Robert Peel
on the self authoring programs and so
forth.
Small team.
We've,
we've thought about going the venture
capital route and expanding and trying to
make a big business out of it.
But our sense was more that,
and maybe we were wrong about this,
but that was better to go directly after
customers and to build the business
incrementally and to test it along
each step and not to get enticed by the
possibility of Unicorn level money.
And so,
um,
anyways,
that's the,
that's the situation there.
And I've got three really
bright people working on this,
um,
open educational platform and
it's really quite exciting.
And I would say we're,
we're well ahead of schedule
from where I thought we would be.
So that's pretty cool.
Have you spoken to Nassim to lab
following your brief Twitter exchange?
We'd love to hear a conversation
with the two of you.
I'd like to talk to him
too because he's very,
very smart.
He's a,
he's touchy though and so I have
some apprehension about that.
I've,
I've talked to lots of touchy people over
the last couple of years and I'm a bit
apprehensive about it,
but I would like to do that.
There's a lot of people
I'd like to talk to.
He's one of them and you know,
it's,
I'm having a hard time setting up those
conversations at the moment because I'm
doing so much touring.
I am talking again to Jonathan Heit
though in the near future and I think
probably to Steven pinker as well.
And by the way,
for those of you who are wondering,
um,
I am going to release the,
and so is Sam.
We're going to release the videos
from the Sam Harris Peterson debates.
Um,
I'll put them on my youtube channel.
Sam,
we'll put them on his will,
make them into podcasts as well.
I'm going to release the first
one on September 1st and uh,
and everyone will have access to it.
Um,
it's taken us a while to figure
out exactly how to do this,
partly because Travis Pangbourne who
hosted the events wanted to raise some
money with the videos,
at least in part to help offset the
costs that he incurred for those events,
which were very expensive,
believe it or not,
and difficult to generate a
profit for from on his end.
Um,
and also he wants to translate the
material that he already has into multiple
languages.
So we agreed to let him win.
We had to make a three
way agreement for this,
you know,
because Sam was involved
and I was involved in,
so it was Pangbourne and so,
and we didn't know how
the events would go,
you know,
so we weren't actually that concerned
with the damn videos to begin with because
we take,
uh,
we,
we'd take an,
uh,
a risk,
I'm not complaining about this by the way,
like I'm not complaining
about taking risks,
but we didn't salmon,
I hadn't even met,
you know,
we didn't know if we were going to have
conversations that were worthwhile.
We didn't know if anybody
would show up for the events.
And so we were way more concerned about
whether or not we'd get a crowd of any
sort,
whether the events would be successful
and whether we could actually talk then
what we would do with the videos if the,
or even if there would be videos
if the events were successful.
And so it turned out that we couldn't
talk and we did have useful discussions.
At least we thought so.
And the audiences responded very well
and there was large crowds and so it was
successful.
So then it turned out that
the videos were worthwhile,
but we hadn't discussed who had control
over the videos or who was going to edit
them or any of those things.
And we had to do that
post hoc after the fact,
which isn't the best way of doing it.
And then it took Travis a while to
assemble a team to do the actual editing.
And so that was our compromise.
And you know,
it would've been better if we could
have released the videos and all of that
immediately after the talks.
But you know,
when you're doing something new and you
don't know exactly what you're doing,
you're not going to do it perfectly.
And so we didn't do that perfectly,
but the events were good.
And I enjoyed talking to Sam and I
learned a lot from the discussion.
I really had to sharpen my thinking.
I really figured out something,
you know,
I figured out that I think the
fundamental issue here is how you take the
infinite world of facts
that presents itself to you,
independent of the value of those facts.
So value neutral facts and they have
to be filtered to a single point,
like a single point of perception because
you have to point your eyes at one
thing and your attention at one
thing and a single point of action.
And so there's a tremendous reducing of
the world of fact to the extraordinarily
simple and targeted rule
of Vail or world of value.
And your,
your brain is the instrument that
does that reducing and it's sort of,
it's in keeping with Elvis Huxley's
suppositions about that and they were
motivated by Henri Bergson the idea that
the brain was a reducing valve and that
what psychedelic experience did
was open the doors of perception.
Something William Blake also talked about.
The brain seems to be in some sense the
part of the structure that reduces the
infinite complexity of the world of facts
to the finite and single point domain
of world of values.
And that's partly neurologically
instantiated and partly sociologically
instantiated become as we
come to a negotiated agreement
about what constitutes
value,
just like we do about what
constitutes economically.
And so the structure that reduces facts
to values is a reducing structure that's
similar caneously and Stan Shealy
instantiated neurologically and
sociologically.
And I understand that a lot more clearly
because I had these discussions with
Sam and I'm writing a lot
about that in this next book,
which is it's a followup.
I s I suspect that's the plan at the
moment to 12 rules for life because I had
written originally 40 rules,
so I have more to go.
I've written about half of the new book
and I spent a lot of time writing about,
at least in part what I had to become
clearer about as a consequence of my
discussions with Harris.
And so I took a look at the videos and
I think the debates were productive and,
and their audiences seem to find them.
So,
and certainly salmon.
I did,
I really enjoyed meeting him.
We got along quite well.
He has much better sense of humor
than I presumed from listening.
Well,
from the two podcasts we did.
Of course,
I wasn't in great humor
when I did those either.
Um,
and you know,
I also think that I'm also,
what would you say I'm a
fan of Sam's motivation?
Uh,
or at least as far as
I could determine it.
I mean,
he wants to ground the world of value
in something that isn't merely arbitrary
revelation.
And Fair enough,
man,
that's a good,
that's a good aim to ground ethics and
something that's solid and not just
arbitrary opinion,
but I think that the
devil's in the details.
And so that's basically what we discussed.
So,
um.